beautiful
seeing the chronicles of narnia on the
big screen for the first time was
nothing short of magical but what if we
told you the film was actually missing a
lot of important details
however when the book was adapted into
the 2005
disney franchise a lot of his original
ideas were sadly left out
including what he actually meant his
characters to look like we know we know
you're probably thinking how could the
casket any better than william mosley
and anna papawell
but it's true almost the entire cast was
meant to look completely different than
what we saw on screen
if you're a hardcore narnia fan buckle
up these differences might be a little
shocking
your adventure begins now
the pavimzi siblings gave i love lucy an
entirely different meaning
she was the reason we got our first
magical glimpse of narnia
and was potentially the most adorable
character in the entire franchise
i'm not a dwarf i'm a girl however c.s
lewis had a completely different image
in mind
when he introduced readers to this
adventurous spirit
although she wasn't given a super
detailed description in the novels
she was described as gay and
golden-haired
her actress georgie henley definitely
got her positivity and happiness down
packed
but she has pretty dark hair that we
wouldn't exactly describe
as golden while this isn't a huge
difference
it's still hard to imagine anyone else
but georgie in the role
it's totally possible that georgie had
an unforgettable audition
that had casting directors throwing
lucy's golden hair description out the
window
it's what's on the inside that counts
right i
think i could be brave enough i'm sure
you could
susan was actually known as the
beautiful one in the novels
while it's no doubt that her actress
anna popplewell is gorgeous
her fierceness and leadership are
probably what fans of the franchise
remember most of her getting her
personality right
sure seemed like the priority when it
came to the film's adaptions
all right now we really should go back
banana actually matches susan's book
description pretty well
we never get a proper visual of how she
appears as a child in the novels but as
an adult
lewis described her as a tall and
gracious woman with black hair that fell
almost to her feet the only part missing
her floor-length hair
while that would have been breathtaking
to see on screen hair that long would
probably get in the way a lot
it's probably best disney keep
characters with absurdly long hair
reserved for just rapunzel it's kind of
her thing
just trying to be realistic no you're
trying to be smart
moving on down the line of paving
siblings edmond's description in the
book series was probably the most
low-key i was just playing along in the
2005 film
edmond was portrayed by actor skander
who has both brown hair and brown eyes
it's still really unclear why lewis
decided not to give edmund an official
description but fans of the series have
used illustrations from the novel
to come to a conclusion on how he was
meant to look they're set on the fact
that edmund was actually meant to have
blonde hair
and blue eyes and he was also cast like
this for the 1988 narnia bbc series
you might have already realized that
this description is wildly different
from how scander looks
but skander still pulled off edmonds
mischievous and cutting ways and
admitted
we were all obsessed we can't leave
these people behind to suffer for it
ah peter pavinzi or as the world knows
him
william mosley say you're sorry all
right
i'm sorry it's a fact that he was
basically the prince charming of the
narnia franchise
with his golden locks blue eyes and
nobility he could rival
any disney prince any day like his
siblings the physical descriptions for
his character were close to none in the
novels
however as an adult lewis describes him
as a tall
chested man and a great warrior it's
also alluded to that his hair was
actually meant to be brown
it's pretty clear that peter's most
redeeming qualities were meant to be
internal however william definitely got
his royalty vibes down packed
are you with me
mr tumnus has to be one of the most
interesting and
loyal friends the pavenzies make during
their time in narnia
in fact he along with lucy actually
introduced us to the entire world
his physical appearance is a little more
complicated than the human qualities of
the pavendis
well here we are come along
as fans of the franchise know tumnus is
a fawn
and cgi definitely worked in disney's
favor when it came to transforming actor
james mcavoy half goat james still got
to keep his bright blue eyes
and his brown hair was transferred from
just his head onto literally every other
part of his body
despite how bizarre mr tumnus looked in
the films his character in the novel was
even more unique
his hair was actually black he had beady
black eyes and his skin was red
while these differences have more to do
with the cgi animators than the casting
itself
it's still interesting to think about
why they made these changes
do you think mr tumnus would have looked
any cooler with red skin
or do you prefer the movie version would
you like to hear some now
the white witch or jadis is absolutely
striking and that's true in both the
novels
and the films of course her thin and
tall demeanor was needed considering she
was
well evil in the film tilda swinton
pulled her off with grace
with her blue gown wild blonde hair and
ice crown
it's hard to imagine that this is almost
the opposite of her physical appearance
in the novels
do you really think that mere force will
deny me my right
lewis described her as beautiful
youthful with skin as white as salt and
long black hair
oh and she was seven feet tall casual
it's hard to say why they decided to
make these changes
we know they had the technology to make
her look like a giant
i mean just look at hagrid in the harry
potter franchise all we know is it
probably would have made her seem
10 times as intimidating what is your
name
son of adam if we're talking rogish
disney princess
we're talking prince caspian with actor
ben barnes
lean and muscular build shaggy black
hair and
smirk he was definitely interesting to
say the least
you will probably be wanting yours back
he was also very much an adult
but what if we told you that prince
caspian was actually meant to be only
13.
you wouldn't believe it right especially
because at the time of the films
ben was 27 but it's true in the novel
not only was he basically a kid but he
was described as a golden-haired boy
the complete opposite of what he
actually looked like this is almost as
shocking as the white witch
being seven feet tall almost you are a
mouse
i was hoping for something a little more
original it's safe to say
will poulter deserves all the credit
when it comes to portraying the most
annoying character in the franchise
eustace his fair hair and light eyes
match the character's entitled attitude
almost too naturally but lewis had a
different vision in mind
though the only description he was given
in the novels was that his personality
matched his appearance
illustrations of the character showed
that he had surprisingly dark hair
not only that but like prince caspian he
was the wrong age
eustis was meant to be just nine years
old but instead the casting director
decided to go with will who was 16 at
the time
that is an outrageous lie we don't know
about you but we haven't met a 16 year
old that looks nine
i mean narnia is a magical land so
anything is possible
right cry
i don't understand we wouldn't blame you
if you could never imagine anyone but
peter
dinklage playing the next character
trumpkin
also known as prince caspian's noble
dwarf who helped him restore his power
and was super important in the disney
franchise with his blue trusting eyes
and golden hair
who wouldn't trust him a simple thank
you would suffice they were doing fine
drowning me without your help
well would you like him as much if he
was betrayed like lewis intended him to
look
trumpkin was meant to have a huge beard
that was coarse and red
and instead his blue eyes were described
as twinkling black eyes
maybe black eyes could be trusting phew
we're glad peter took over the role
for this one but it's still strange they
didn't at least give him black contacts
to wear
haven't enough of us died already
diggory kirk potentially the most
important character of all
he was old wise and gave off major
grandfather vibes
this may be one character that the films
actually got 100
right in fact lewis's only description
of him
was an old wise professor she's your
sister didn't she
you're a family actor jim broadbents
unkempt white hair
small round spectacles and fancy attire
was nothing short of spot on when it
came to portraying this character
even digree's cartoon version in another
adaptation
showed off his professor's vibes
perfectly imagine if
every teacher dressed like kirk that
would be interesting
try me jinnarbrich like trumpkin was a
dwarf but a black dwarf
not to mention instead of being a hero
was an accomplice to the white witch
in the films he was played by kieran
shaw and was plump
short with a beard and hair that was
almost always concealed underneath a red
winter hat
not exactly intimidating yes our little
prince uncomfortable we're here to
report that his book appearance was
just as soft like in the film he was
described as plump and short but with a
beard that touched the ground and a red
cap
that very much resembled an elf so
basically he looks like a belonging at
the north pole
sorry dinar break i didn't do anything
wrong how dare you address the queen of
nanya
i didn't know we're adding another black
dwarf to the list
and this time it's a nickabrite like his
companion he was short plump but his
hair and beard were gray
with age and his eyes were blue thanks
to actor
warwick davis i'd gladly do it again if
it would rid us of these
barbarians while his physical appearance
isn't a huge matter to the storyline
the novels portray him with black hair
instead of gray and his eyes are a much
more intimidating color
black what's up with this franchise
changing everyone's eye color to
i told you we should have killed him
when we had the chance no matter how old
this world narnia may seem
it still might be bizarre to think that
santa claus actually paid a visit to the
vivinzi siblings in both the films and
the books
when we first see father christmas in
the films you wouldn't assume it was
good old saint nick from just looking at
him
he was super modernized and lacked his
traditionally huge jolly belly
he had a naturally kept beard and was
wearing more of an armor-like santa suit
however in the novel lewis did not hold
back on the traditional vibes
he wore a bright red robe had a
significantly plump stomach
and a long beard that covered his torso
maybe the narnia creators thought it was
just a tad too
tacky i thought there was no christmas
in narnia
no for a long time it might be kind of
hard to watch the films the same way
ever again but it's also pretty cool to
see how the same character can look so
different
it's truly what's on the inside that
matters which character do you think had
the most shocking difference
did getting all of this info make you
look at the films differently
maybe it's time to give the novels a
read let us know all your royal thoughts
in the comment section below don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a thumbs up
time to climb out of the wardrobe
you